ever play a Bioware game and then play
the same mission over and over and over
again do it differently every time to
see how it plays out it's kind of like
that source code now in source code the
government has the technology to send a
person's consciousness back through time
into another person's body for the last
eight minutes of that other person's
life before they die so it turns out the
movie takes place on the train from
unbreakable and the bomb has gone off
and killed everyone in it Jake
Gyllenhaal needs to find the bomber so
we can avert the immediate next disaster
and now we have source code and so he's
gonna live these eight minutes and do it
over and over and over again until he
succeeds it's ultimately trial and error
and anyone who's played old-school games
knows trial and error and the
frustration you can't change the past in
this movie you can only see and you
know help the future don't worry that
shits in the trailer don't kill me now
first of all the acting and source code
was really good Gyllenhaal was really
good and I think he needed this movie
people needed to remember that he's more
than you know forgettable the chick from
Gone Baby Gone Zinn it she's really good
as is the hot chick from the departed
yeah you got your hot chicks in this
movie yeah and the guy who played Colin
Powell in WK he's in the movies a bit of
a prick doctor all doctors are aren't
they now I was really surprised that I
really liked source code and what
fascinated me is the prospect that I can
watch the same eight minutes loop over
and over and over again for an hour and
a half and be entertained
well yeah it's more than eight minutes
in between missions he talks with the
people tells him what he saw and he goes
back here's the best way I can describe
source code if Groundhog Day and 24 had
a kid that took place in an eight-minute
loop source code now anything that deals
with time are looking back on time or
glimpsing on time living a shadow of
time you run into some loopholes and to
my surprise this movie didn't have a lot
you think it does and then by the end of
the movie if you've listened to
everything everyone's saying wraps it up
pretty well not saying I don't have
those couple issues where I'm like wait
a minute if that's true then how is that
true but still it doesn't take away from
the movie the movie still good how good
well when I got home from watching
source code I look back on all the
reviews that I did and the movies are
reviewed and I gotta say of 2011 this is
the best movie so far it was gonna get
that I would buy it even on blu-ray
rating but the fact remains and I
you guys not source code almost made me
cry I swear to you by the end of the
movie he is rough so I got to give
source code the awesome tacular
it was good you might have your issues
with the movie you might not like the
fact that it ultimately is the same
eight minute loop played a little
differently every time but you can't
hate source code the acting was good the
intrigue was great the movie keeps you
guessing and I wasn't able to guess the
movie that's always a plus so go check
out source code of 2011 right now it's
the best movie out but if you liked what
you seen here and you want to see more
click right here to see more